welcome everybody to uh the opening
ceremony of the saint louis rapid and
blitz i will be your host tonight
christian carrillo first of all i would
like to say uh thank you to shannon
bailey and her staff here at the world
chess hall of fame for uh putting this
beautiful opening ceremony together as
well as
bringing the history and culture of
chess through the world chess hall of
fame here in st louis thank you shannon
second of all i would like uh to
highlight two visionaries uh without
which none of this would be possible
here in st louis two people that have
emerged their love for a chess as well
as their love for the city of saint
louis and gave us the saint louis chess
campus and the world chess hall of fame
here and gave so much pleasure to chess
fans around the world of course i'm
talking about dr ginny and rex sinfield
[Applause]
i would also like to highlight the
visionary behind the grand chess tour
that is the 13th world champion mr gary
kasparov
as well as the executive director of the
grand chester michael kodakowski
and of course
two people that make everything happen
here in st louis around the chess campus
the big dog tony rich the executive
director as well as joy bray
[Applause]
and of course the grand chess tour is a
global event and we need partners and we
have some amazing partners i would like
to thank our partners in europe super
bad
they have been doing an amazing job
putting together incredible shows in uh
bucharest in warsaw in uh zagreb they
have been an amazing partner for us and
of course uh the st louis chess club who
will be putting the last two stops of
the grand chess tour the shows here in
st louis
and now i would like to give the word to
tony rich tony
[Applause]
thank you thank you thank you hi
everyone and welcome to the opening
ceremony for the 2022 st louis rapid and
blitz
you know it's crazy to think that this
is the fifth year we've held the st
louis rapid and blitz it's the seventh
year for the grand chess tour because we
missed 2020.
you know over those seven years that
we've had this grand chess tour it's
gone from all classical to a couple of
classical couple of rapid and blitz to
one crazy year where we had eight
tournaments i think spread across the
globe including india and europe
you know it was just amazing this year
is no different really this tournament
this season i should say of the grand
chess tour really represents the
culmination of everything that we've
done so far year by year we try to make
each event better we try to make the
tour better and we try to make sure that
our sponsors fans and players alike are
all happy with the the events and the
production that goes along with it and i
for one have to say i really am so a
round of applause for everybody who
makes that happen
it's crazy also to think that we've
awarded 8.6 million dollars in prize
money since the grand chess tour started
just think of that alone
magnus won it twice wesley won it twice
hecaro won the tour once and ding lorin
won the tour once so it'll be really
interesting to see who wins the grand
chess tour this year as well i have one
last thing i wrote down here
you shouldn't try to become a super
grand master
you shouldn't jess is really hard right
so
you're going to spend your life
traveling around the world
never at home
you're going to study and study and
study hours a day on your own with your
coaches looking at books databases chess
engines any resource that you can find
to give you an edge over your opponent
takes focus and if you've ever lost a
game of chess you know how painful that
can be right so not only do you have to
play an entire tournament but you have
to play an entire tournament after you
had a really really really painful loss
becoming a super grand master is
incredibly difficult i don't encourage
it for anyone but
for those that have made it to this
super grand master status you are our
superstars of the chessword you're our
idols you are the people who have proved
to us that through dedication effort
focus
you know never seeing your family always
being away that the human mind is really
capable of some amazing things so it's
wonderful to have you all here in st
louis i'd like to thank you very much
for making the st louis rapid and blitz
and the sinkfield cup both such
strong tournaments and amazing
tournaments and i can't wait to see you
all play
[Applause]
and i'll wrap things up by introducing
the godmother of chess not just here in
the united states
but around the world dr jeanne singfield
[Applause]
thanks tony
well i thought i'd tell you a little fun
story
okay i know you guys think of this chess
as being st louis
but chess is also missouri
okay the first world championship
was here
in st louis missouri and this year to
celebrate 200 years of missouri
i taught
two life scouts remember me and my
scouts 250 000 kids earning the chesmar
badge
to build a bicentennial chess board
which is 14 square feet
with 36 images and graves celebrating
the history of missouri and the governor
of the state because it's in front of
the capitol came and took it
as a representative of 250 years of
chess so we're going to show these other
countries missouri and st louis's chest
[Applause]
so
anyway it's it's nice i my job is always
to introduce rex
so i'm looking at the audience to see
how many of the old jokes i've tried
[Laughter]
so
but he's been very supportive you see
and you know he encourages my crazy
we're up to 11 translations my booklet
we now have uzbek russian and swahili
recently so
those of you who aren't here and you
feel like you were obligated to
translate to learn to read and write
chess in another language
bring it on
so let me introduce the godfather of
american chess
who
is maybe not a world-class chess player
but he's a world-class supporter
[Applause]
thank you genie and thank you for not
telling any of those old jokes um so
i want to welcome all of you to st louis
this is my favorite time of the year
and probably my favorite event of the
year other than watching the st louis
cardinals in the world series which of
course we'll get to do this year
ricardo is snickering there
so
first i want to thank the staff
of the chess club joy bray and tony rich
and the world chess hall of fame
shannon bailey
and all their staff the great curator of
the world chess hall of fame for
everything they do to make both
organizations tremendous successes
and i want to thank the contractors and
vendors randy and his team at spectrum
studios kevin and his crew at silverback
and all those who make the broadcast
alive and incredible success
i also want to recognize of course the
greatest broadcast team in the history
of any sport grand master yasser cyril 1
grand master peter svidler and grand
master christian chirilla
[Applause]
i want to remind some of you you're a
stand-in for jennifer shahady so do a
good job she's over in barcelona winning
money in poker
so and lastly
while you're here in the next several
days or weeks take time to go through
the fischer spassky exhibit it is truly
incredible all the items that we've
developed
and i tell the story about three or four
weeks ago as we were developing putting
this together we thought it was kind of
a secret we didn't let the word out but
out of the blue joy bray gets a phone
call from france from boris baskey jr
so we didn't do a good job of keeping
that a secret and he says that he has a
lot of items that his father
would like to loan to the exhibition so
that was a great surprise so we spent
sent three people over to france they
checked it out they were suitably
impressed
and so that will be added to the exhibit
as well and it's really hard to believe
yesterday and i were talking about this
that it's been 50 years since
fisher's victory it seems like yesterday
that we're seeing all of this on
tv and in the newspapers around the
world
so but it was a great event and the
exhibit is equally great and i hope you
all enjoy it and now let me bring back
christian chirilla
thank you rex
it's time to uh get down to business and
meet the superstars uh the players that
are going to regale us with their moves
for the next few weeks we're going to
start with sam shanklin representing
united states
hikaru nakamura representing united
states
[Applause]
ali reza firuja representing france
mama de yarov representing azerbaijan
lanier dominguez representing the united
states
maxim vashir lagrav representing france
levon aronian representing the united
states
[Applause]
also representing the united states
fabiano caruana
[Applause]
one of the players that will play for
the world championship title next year
jan nepomnyashi
and last but not least jeffrey shong
representing the united states
jeffrey i will start uh with you some q
a
how do you feel to be playing against
the best chess players in the world
uh yeah i mean it's definitely an
incredible honor
to receive this opportunity especially
kind of as a last-minute replacement
i think having last year
last year's experience of playing here
will will help
how much it will help i guess we'll find
out pretty soon
i would uh like you to pass the
microphone to jan
oh you have one
first of all uh you enthralled us with
your chest during the candace that was
just an incredible inspiring performance
um how are you going into this next
world championship match in terms of
mentality
well thank you for your very kind words
about my performance and
i guess i didn't have any problems with
mentality but i had a problem with my
result so
hopefully the result will be better this
time
thank you very much hikaru
uh you don't consider yourself a chess
player nowadays but you have been
putting amazing performance after
amazing performance in the last couple
of years how do you balance your
streaming career with professional chess
and over-the-board chess as well well i
mean first of all i still do play
professional chess so saying that i'm
not a not a professional i mean that's a
little bit far and obviously uh it's
great to be back in st louis i mean i
won this won this event last year
i mean a result that i think is very
hard to match um i think at the end of
the day they're 24 hours in a day and i
think during covet in particular i
learned how to use that time find a way
to um just balance everything and it's
just been a lot of fun balancing
streaming and playing chess so i'm
having a great time and during kovid you
were also mentioning that a lot of
players did not practice did not play as
many competitive games while you were
playing a lot online do you feel that
gives you an edge
yeah i mean i think certainly uh not
even just with myself but i think you
also see it in general you see a lot of
junior players so i think during the
pandemic they weren't able to play
tournaments but they were studying
playing online and improving immensely
and now you see the results so it wasn't
just me but i think it was a very unique
situation for everybody and i mean some
people found the motivation to study i
think for a lot of people i i mean i
can't speak for fabian or jan but i mean
when you play a tournament and then the
middle it's postponed for i don't know
six months i mean i i don't know how how
we're supposed to deal with that so we
just go play a tournament after
tournament and suddenly you you don't
know when you're playing again so it's
just a very unique situation for
everybody it's great to have you back in
st louis hikaru ali reza first of all
welcome uh to st louis how does it feel
to be here at the st louis chess club
and play against the best chess players
in the world
yeah i'm happy to be here it's my first
time to be in saint louis um
yeah i grew up watching this and noise
events i always had the dream to belay
once in this chess club
because it started in 2013 i think and i
also started playing chess at that time
so
um it's an honor to be here for me and
playing all the great players
did the campus and the st louis chess
club meet your expectations
yeah i think it's a great chess club um
it's one of the greatest i have seen at
least so
i'm really happy that there is some
places like this in the world about
chess
already thank you very much with that
being said i would like to invite mr
chris bird on the stage we will be doing
the drawing of lots
thank you
um
thank you
um the first thing i would like to do is
uh introduce my deputy arbiters for the
event so please uh everybody give a
round of applause to aries margaret and
karen penner
yeah go ahead stand
now they're hopefully going to do most
of the work for me at this event so
that's
that's why i hire them right
um so i've been asked to speak a little
bit about the format of the event um so
over the next five days starting
tomorrow we're going to see these guys
battle it out over nine rapid games and
18 blitz games
gonna take all the points from those uh
games that they play combine them into
one total overall score and hopefully
come up with a winner without needing a
playoff
um but if we need a playoff we'll do
that as well so get some more excitement
for everyone uh if need be
so um the next thing we're going to do
is do the
drawing of lots so for each of the rapid
portion and the blitz portion we need to
draw pairing numbers for the players
this will determine uh what color they
have against each opponent uh throughout
the entire tournament
and um
we're gonna do that by giving them some
wonderful books
the mind art experience
which discusses 10 years of chess and
culture in st louis
and also a fridge magnet from the
fischer um
spassky match in 1972.
so i'm gonna leave christian to call up
the players in his
um
chosen order and that way i can maintain
a nice relationship they're going to
hate me for this all right
and um please
please what you're gonna do is um when
you come up you're gonna pick a book
which will be your rapid pairing number
and then the magnet will be the blitz uh
pairing number and mr rich here is gonna
uh announce the number um and the player
when he sees that i'm going to call uh
mr sam shanklin to the stage first
[Applause]
thank you
sam has pairing number nine
and number four
next on stage will be chakriar mamedyaro
[Applause]
shaq picks his book
chooses number seven
so you'll have pairing number seven in
the rapid and in the blitz tournament he
chooses a magnet
and he has number five number seven and
five
[Applause]
next on the stage will be jeffrey shong
[Applause]
jeffrey considers
his moves
flips it over and he has perry number
one
and in the blitz tournament
jeffrey will have pairing number nine
next on stage mr yann nepomnyashi
[Applause]
john has pairing number 10 for rapid and
pairing number eight for blitz
next will be all right you guessed it
fabiano caruana
[Applause]
fabiano caruana
pairing number two for rapid
and number 10 for blitz
[Applause]
next is ali reza firuja
[Applause]
alarisa chooses pairing number four for
rapid
and pairing number three for blitz
next is hikaru nakamura
[Applause]
christian chose a very diplomatic order
to call them up and pairing number eight
for rapid
and number one for blitz
next in line maxine vashir lagrav
[Applause]
maxime chooses pairing number six for
rapid and
also number six for blitz
[Applause]
and last but not least and hope you're
not going to hate me forever levon
aronian
two more left lebron aronian second to
last
[Applause]
lavon picks his book and chooses rapid
pairing number
five
and his blitz pairing number shall be
number two
five and two right
linear dominguez
so we have pairing number three left in
rapid and he chooses that and we have
pairing number seven left in blitz and
he has number seven in blitz
[Applause]
and it does seem that i forgot to
introduce my fellow partners in crime
the legends yasser sarawan
peter zwiddler please stand up
[Applause]
as well as the uh the production
assistant for this tournament grand
master alejandro ramirez
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
and the granchester journalist woman
grandmaster anastasia karlovic
[Applause]
and with that we say goodbye to the
opening ceremony the show will be
starting tomorrow central time 1pm you
can watch it on youtube on twitch on the
saint louis just club channels as well
as on granchester.org
we will see you tomorrow
so
see how it goes
[Music]
you